تقرير صادم عن كراهيه الشرطه للنساء
وضحايا سوء سلوك بعض ضباطها يطالبون
باجتثات العناصر الفاسده كما هذه الضحيه
التي ترفض الكشف عن اسمها
وكل من ارتبط اسمه بحاله مشبوهه حتى وان
كانت مرتبطه بعنف منزلي بسيط فيجب التحقيق
فيها العضو في مجلس اللوردات لويس كيسي
اعدت مراجعه مستقله في اعقاب جرائم
ارتكبها افراد الشرطه من بينها جريمه
اغتصاب وقت ضابط شرطه لساره افران وجرائم
اخرى ضد النساء المراجعه خلصت الى ان شرطه
العاصمه لندن عنصريه ومنحازه ضد المراه
وغير منضبطه
اولا ليس كل من يعمل في شرطه العاصمه
عنصريا لكن هناك افراد عنصريون فيها ثانيا
وجدنا ان عناصر الشرطه انفسهم عانوا من
العنصريه سواء من خلال استطلاع ارائهم او
تقديم شهاداتهم ثالثا هل الشرطه تمارس
التحمل والتمييز نعم
الاخفاقات الجسيمه في شرطه لندن كمؤسسه
امنيه استدعت اتخاذ اجراءات جذريه بعد
سنوات من الانكار لحجم العنصريات المتاصله
وخذلان النساء والاطفال بحسب التقرير الذي
رد عليه السير مارك راولي مفوض الشرطه
لندن
لا يمكنك قراءه هذا التقرير ولا تنزعج بعض
ما جاء في التقرير محرج ومغضب ومذل لا
سيما شهادات الرجال والنساء في المؤسسه
التي اديرها اهتم بهم بشده يريدون ان نفعل
ما هو افضل وشيئا مختلف وانا مصمم على
الاصلاح وكسب ثقه الشرطه وما هو افضل
لسكان لندن
تعليقا على التقرير قالت وزيره الداخليه
ان الشرطه خذلت ثقه الناس واخلت بالقياده
وبثقافه الشرطه وبالمعايير فيما اعتبرت
المعرضات هذه الاخفاقات نتيجه سياسه
الحكومه غير الفعاله وتقليص ميزانيتها
الشرطه قبلت بنتائج المراجعه المستقله
وستدرس توصيتها للتخلص من العنصريه
والعناصر ذوي السلوك السيء فيما تدعم
الحكومه قائد الشرطه لاعاده ثقه الناس في
اكبر مؤسسه امنيه في البلاد لكن هذا قد
يستغرق بعض الوقت مصطفى العربيه لندن